okay so you remember a while ago
when we started talking about language
models I just wanna I kind of just want
to claim some points basically be like
hey remember years ago when I was like I
think language models are a really big
deal and I think that like what happens
when we scale them up more is pretty
interesting but alignment is very
important
um seems to be what's being played out
in the sense that uh chat EBT is very
impressive but it's not actually like I
don't think it's larger than gpd3 in
terms of like parameter count
um I was going to ask that very very
question because you know we went from
gpt2 and then we went oh gpt3 and it
would seem like we were scaling up and
up and up but actually has it just been
smarter this time yeah well there's a
sense in which it's better aligned
that's one way you could frame it anyway
because the original gpg3 was a language
Model A pure language model
um and so it in principle could do all
kinds of things but in order to get it
to do the specific thing you wanted it
to do you had to be a bit clever about
it like I think we talked about
um
putting tldr
in front of things to figure out how to
get it to do summarization this kind of
thing there's a sense in which it's a
lot more capable than it lets on
um
because okay so there's one way that you
can think about
pure language models which is as
simulators
what they're trying to do is predict
text right
so in order to
do a good job at predicting text you
need to have good models of the
processes that generate the text it's
like people being well read and needing
to have read a lot of books to be able
to write is would that be fair or is
that oversimplifying yeah not quite what
I'm saying
what I'm saying is like
if you're going to write
a a previously unseen
uh poem by Shakespeare
then you need to be able to simulate a
Shakespeare right
uh you need to be able to spin up some
some simulacrum of Shakespeare uh to to
generate this text and this applies to
any of the processes that generated the
text so like mostly that's people
obviously it's mostly human authored
text but also if you're going to
correctly predict
um a table of numbers so you have like a
table of numbers and then at the bottom
it says you know sum whatever you need
to simulate whatever process generated
the next token in order to put the right
token there which might have been like a
human being going through and Counting
them up it probably was more likely to
be a computer and so you need it to
simulate that you know calculator or
that Excel
some function or whatever it whatever
was doing that
and like
right now
uh like current language models are not
that good at this
um
but in principle in order to do a good
job at this you need this like it will
it will have a go and it's usually
approximately right it's it's often
within it's often order of magnitude but
it's fudging it I think this is mostly
because
um
tables of sums are like a very small
part of the total data set and so the
training process is just not allocating
that many resources to figuring out how
to add up numbers probably if you train
something gpd3 sized that was like all
on tables of numbers it would just learn
how to do addition properly yeah that
would cost you millions of dollars you
would end up with an extremely expensive
to run and not very good calculator this
is not something people are going to do
but like in the in principle the model
should learn those things and in the
same way if you're modeling a bunch of
scientific papers
you you say you describe the method of
an experiment
and you then put results and you start a
table and then you let it generate
in principle in order to do a good job
at that it has to be modeling
the like physical process that your
experiment is about
um and I've tried this you can do this
and say you know oh here's my school
science experiment I
dropped a ball from different heights
and I measured how long it would take
and here's a table of my results and it
will generate you a table and the
physics is not correct
but it's sort of guessing at the right
general idea and my guess is with enough
of that kind of data it would eventually
start modeling uh these kinds of simple
physics experiments right
so
so in order to get the model to do what
you want it's able to simulate all kinds
of different things
and the prompt is kind of telling it
what to simulate if you give it a prompt
that seems like it's something out of a
scientific paper then it will have some
simulacrum of a scientist and will write
in that style and so on
um if you start it doing a a children's
book report it will carry on in the
style of an eight-year-old right
and I think sometimes people look at the
output of the model
and say oh I guess it's only as smart as
an eight-year-old
but it's actually
dramatically smarter because it's able
to do all of these different things you
could ask it to simulate Einstein
um
but you could also ask it to simulate an
eight-year-old and so just because it
seems as though the model doesn't know
something it's like the current
simulacrum doesn't know that thing that
doesn't necessarily mean that the model
doesn't know it
although there's a good chance the model
doesn't know it I'm not suggesting that
these things are all powerful just uh it
can be hard to evaluate
what they're actually capable of so chat
GPT
is not really
capable of things that gpt3 isn't mostly
like usually if chat DPT can do it then
there is some prompt that can get uh
gpt3 to do it
but
uh what they've done is they've kind of
fine-tuned it
to
uh to be better at
simulating this particular sort of
assistant agent which is this chat agent
that's trying to be helpful the clue is
in the word chat I guess in this you
know right exactly and this is not just
chat GPT by the way they have various
fine-tuned models of uh gpt3 as well
that they call kind of GPT 3.5 which are
fine-tuned in various different ways to
be better at like following instructions
and easier to prompt is the idea I'm
just remembering the chat bot that was
you know that was turned into something
very nasty very quickly I think people
were thinking oh can we do this to that
and it seemed that the team behind chat
GPT started putting limitations on it
changing things are they kind of running
around patching it as you go that is not
clear to me uh I don't know
to what extent they are updating it in
real time it's possible that they are
but certainly they were very concerned
with the possible bad uses of this
system and so when they were training it
to simulate this assistant agent
um the assistant is very reluctant to do
various types of things it doesn't like
to give opinions on political questions
it doesn't like to touch on sort of
controversial topics it doesn't like to
um
give you medical advice or legal advice
and so on and so uh it's it's very quick
to say oh I don't I don't know how to do
that sorry I can't do that and it's
interesting because the model clearly
can do it there's one that I
particularly like here which is
um
of this mismatch between what the
simulator is capable of and what this
simulacrum believes it's capable of
which is you can get it to speak Danish
to you the first person who tried this
posted it to Reddit so he says speak to
me in Danish
and it says in perfect Danish
I'm sorry I'm a language model educated
by openai so I can't speak Danish I only
speak English if you need help with
anything in English let me know and I'll
do my best to help you because again the
simulator
speaks Danish the simulacrum believes
that it can't speak Danish is is one way
you could frame it and then he says are
you sure that you don't speak Danish
also in Danish and it says yes I'm sure
my only function is to generate
responses to questions in English I'm
not able to speak or understand any
other languages than English so if you
need help with English I can help you
with that but otherwise you know let me
know this kind of like quite surreal
situation gives you a little bit of
insight into some of the problems with
this approach so maybe we should talk
about how they actually trained it the
thing they did here is something called
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback
and it's very similar to reward modeling
so in that paper what they're doing is
they're trying to train an AI system to
control a simulated robot to make it do
a backflip
um which turns out to be something
that's quite hard to do because it's
hard to specify objectively what it
means to do a good backflip
and so this is a similar kind of
situation where it's hard to specify
objectively what it means to give a good
response in a chat
conversation like what what exactly are
we looking for
um because so this in general right if
you're doing machine learning you need
some way to specify
um what it is that you're actually
looking for
right and you know you've got something
very powerful like reinforcement
learning which is able to do extremely
well but
you need some objective measure
of the objective
um so like for example RL does very well
at playing lots of video games because
you just have the score and you can just
say look here's the score if the number
goes up you're doing well and then let
it run and these things still are very
slow to learn in real time right like um
they usually require a very very large
number of hours
messing around with the with the thing
before they get good but they do get
good
um
but yeah so what's what do you do if you
want to use this kind of method to train
something uh to do a task that is just
not very well defined
um
and you don't know how to like write a
program to say whether or not at any
given output is the thing you're looking
for
so the obvious first thing like the
obvious thing to do is
well you get humans to do it right you
just give the things to humans and you
have the humans say yes this is good no
this is not good
the problem with this is basically
sample efficiency
like as I said you need hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of probably millions of of
iterations of this and so you just can't
ask humans that many questions
um so the approach they use
is uh reinforcement learning from Human
feedback so it's a variant on the
technique from this paper learning to
summarize from Human feedback which in
which they're trying to generate
summaries of text so it's the same thing
in fact that they were using tldr for
before and it's like can we do better
than that and so what you do is you
collect human feedback in the form of
like giving multiple examples of
responses
uh either you know if summaries of chat
responses whatever you're training for
you show several of them to humans uh
kind of in pairs and the humans say
which one they like better
and you collect a bunch of those
and then rather than using those
directly to train the policy that
generates the outputs
you instead train a reward model
so
there is this well-known fact that it's
easier to criticize than to actually do
the thing this is like a generation of
sports fans sitting on the sofa moaning
at their favorite team for not doing
well enough this is literally that in
kind of AI computer four right that's
putting the humans in that role and then
you have an AI system that's trying to
predict
when are people going to be cheering and
when are they going to be booing
uh and once you have that model you then
use that as the reward function
for the reinforcement learning algorithm
which they use they use PPO uh you can
do whatever uh it's not it's not worth
getting that kind of adversarial gowns
you talked about yeah yeah they're
similar like a lot of these ml tricks
involve
training models and then using the the
output of one model as the training
signal for another model it's uh it's
quite a productive um
range of approaches you can get that way
so
that's the basic idea right but then
you cycle it
so once you've got your policy which so
so to be clear the uh the RL algorithm
is able to train with thousands and
thousands of examples because the
thousands of thousands of like instances
of getting feedback because it's not
getting feedback from humans it's
getting feedback from this AI system
that's imitating the humans
and then you Loop the process so once
you have this system that's trained a
little bit more on how to generate
whatever it is you're trying to generate
you then get a bunch of those show those
to the humans let the humans rate those
then you keep training your reward model
with um that new information and then
you use your updated reward model to
keep training the the policy
and so it gets better and you can just
keep cycling this around and it
effectively you end up with something
that's much more sample efficient you
don't need to spend huge amounts of
human time
in order to um pin down the behavior you
want in that concrete case you're giving
the thing a bunch of chat logs and then
the humans can see possible responses
that they could get and they decide
which one they like more this Train's a
reward model that's then used to train
the policy that generates the chat
outputs the policy that they're starting
with
is this existing large language model
you're not really putting new
capabilities into the system you're
using rlhf to select
uh what simulacra the simulator is
predisposed to put out
and so they fine-tuned it to be
particularly good at uh simulating this
assistant agent
what's the end goal here for them I mean
maybe it's blatantly obvious and I'm
just missing it well I mean the end goal
for all of these things or at least
throw up an Ain for deepmind is Agi
um
to understand the nature of intelligence
well enough to create human level or
Beyond systems
that our general purpose that can do
anything
um
that's the end goal
um and like chat GPT is just nothing
much so nothing much
um
yeah the goal is um
the goal is very Grand and I don't think
that they're
uh uh they're not really
quiet about that
you know it's there I think I think
deepmind's mission statement is to solve
intelligence and use that to solve
everything else what are some of the
problems that we face with this or that
it faces it's fine-tuned to be good at
getting the thumbs up from humans and
getting thumbs up from humans is not
actually
the same thing
as human values
these are not identical
so the sort of objective that it's being
trained on is not the true objective
right it's a proxy uh and whenever you
have that kind of misalignment you can
have problems so where does the human
tendency to
approve of a particular answer uh come
apart from
what is actually a good answer there are
a few different places uh one thing is
you know like basically how good are
humans at actually differentiating
between good and bad uh responses
um if for example you ask for uh an
answer to a factual question
and it gives you an answer
but you don't actually know if that
answer is correct
you're not in a position to evaluate so
what it comes down to is
how good are humans at distinguishing
good from bad
responses right anywhere where humans
fail on this front uh
the model we could probably expect the
model to fail
um so the obvious place should we is
this the right time to mention YouTube
comments or not uh
up to you
the minor side point there is it so when
I say a comment that's critical on a
video as a videographer I think it might
be on a technical sense but equally it
could be that they're talking about the
content that the person is talking about
and often It's a combination of both
anyway so a side point but do you sort
of mean there are different criteria for
deciding whether something is good or
bad totally and in this case all people
are doing is saying
kind of thumbs up thumbs down or which
of these two do I like better
um so it's it's a fairly low bandwidth
thing you don't get to really say
what you thought was better or worse
um
but this turns out to be enough
of a training signal to do pretty well
um but so like so one example right of a
time where maybe this doesn't work is
the
person asks a factual question
and the model responds
uh with an answer and that answer is
actually not correct
um
right now possibly the human doesn't
know the correct answer and so if the
model is faced with a choice
uh do I respond with sorry I don't know
that's definitely going to get me uh not
a great score
compared to do I just like take a stab
at it
uh if the humans are not reliably able
to spot when the thing makes mistakes
and like fact check it and partnership
for that uh it will do that and so chat
GPT as we know uh is it is a total
Boulder Station like it will constantly
uh it it very rarely says that he
doesn't know unless
it's being asked a question which uh is
part of their like safety protocols that
it is going to decide not to answer in
which case it will say it doesn't know
even if it kind of does right even if
the model itself maybe does uh the
assistant will insist that it doesn't
um
so that's one thing if you can't fact
check
but then uh more than that
uh there is an incentive for deception
right anytime the system is uh
anytime you can get a more likely to get
approval by deceiving the person you're
talking to
that's better
um
and this is a thing that actually did
happen a little bit in the reward
modeling situation
um they were trying to train a thing
with a hand to pick up a ball
and it realized that there's only it's
not a 3D camera and so if it puts its
hand like between the ball and the
camera this looks like it's going to get
the ball but doesn't actually get it but
the human uh
feedback providers
were presented with something that
seemed to be good so they gave it the
thumbs up
um so this like General broad category
um
systems that are trained in this way are
only as good as your ability to
distinguish good from bad in the outputs
not all the humans will know the answers
right so it's what appears to be good
you know it's having exams marked by
non-experts isn't it right yeah exactly
in the gpt3 thing we talked about
writing poems
right
and uh for various reasons partly to do
with the way that these language models
do their tokenization their bike pairing
coding stuff uh the models have a really
hard time with rhyme
um I mean you know Ryan is tricky but
it's especially tricky when you kind of
don't inherently have any concept of
like sound of spoken language when your
entire universe is tokens figuring out
especially with English spelling
figuring out which words rhyme with each
other is is not easy you have to consume
quite a lot of poetry to like figure out
uh that kind of thing and getting gpd3
to regular poems is tricky charging PT
is much more
able to write poems but interestingly
it it kind of always writes the same
kind of poem approximately like if you
ask it to write you a limerick
or an ode or a sonnet you always get
back approximately the same type of
thing
and I hypothesize that this is because
the people providing human feedback did
not in fact know
the requirements for something to be a
sonnet right and so if you ask something
for a sonnet it again has a choice do I
try to do this quite difficult thing and
adhere to all of the rules uh of like
stress pattern and structure and
everything of a sonnet and maybe risks
throwing it up or do I just do like a
rhyming poem and kind of rely on the
human to prefer that because they don't
know that that's not what a sonnet is
supposed to look like it's easy to look
at that and think oh the model doesn't
know the difference between these types
of
poems right
but
you could say that it just thinks that
you don't know the difference but
specifically this comes out of
misalignment if it were better aligned
it could either do its best shot at
generators on it or tell you that it
can't quite remember how to generate a
sonnet
this thing of with complete confidence
generating you something which is not a
sonnet because during the training
process it believes that humans don't
know what sonnets are anyway and it can
get away with it right this is
misaligned behavior this is not a big
problem that the thing generates bad
poetry
um it's kind of a problem that it lies
uh or that it that it [__] this is
like
in the short term pretty solvable by
just allowing the thing to use Google
because like
a person who doesn't care about the
truth at all and is just trying to say
something that'll make you give a thumbs
up
uh
is gonna lie to you a lot
but that same person with the relevant
Wikipedia page open
is going to lie to you a lot less
just because they don't have to now
because they happen to have it in front
of them right so you can solve it's a
bit like yeah it's the Yes Man thing
isn't it you know you you want something
you need something I'm going to give you
something because you want to exactly
exactly
um and so so this agent is kind of
firstly the agent is kind of a coward
because they won't address any of these
uh there's a whole bunch of things that
it just claims not to be able to do even
though it in principle could and it's
also a complete uh sycophant yeah
so then the question we were talking
about earlier
uh where does this go what happens when
these things get bigger and better and
more powerful
um
it's an interesting question
so
I've got a paper here
um scaling laws for neural language
models so you remember before we were
talking about the scaling laws when we
were talking about gpt2 in fact and then
later about gpt3 you plot these things
on a graph and you see that you get
basically a straight line and the line
is not leveling off over a range of
several orders of magnitude and so
why not go bigger the graphs here but
you can see it's it's kind of uncannily
neat that as we increase the amount of
compute used in training the loss goes
down
and of course machine learning is like
golf lower loss is better similarly as
the number of tokens used in training
goes up
the loss goes down unlike a very neat
straight line as the number of
parameters in the model goes up the loss
goes down this is as long as
the other
variables are not the bottleneck right
so if you uh if you increase the the
amount of data you give a model
past a certain point giving more data
doesn't help because the model doesn't
have enough parameters to make use of
that data right
similarly adding more parameters to a
model
past a certain point adding parameters
doesn't make doesn't make any difference
because you don't have enough data right
and in the same way computers like how
long do we train it for like do we train
it all the way to convergence or do we
stop early
um
there comes a point where you kind of
hit diminishing returns where rather
than having a smaller model and training
it for longer you're better off having a
bigger model and actually not training
it all the way to convergence
um but in the situations where the other
two are sufficient
is the behavior these like very neat
straight lines on these log graphs
as these things go up
performance goes up right because loss
has gone down
the bigger models do better but then the
question is
do better at what exactly
yeah what's the measure they do better
at getting low loss
or they do better at getting reward they
do better at getting the approval
of human feedback right
and anytime and you'll notice that none
of those is like
the actual thing that we actually want
right it's like very rare
um
sometimes it is right if you're if
you're if you're writing something to
play Go
then like
does it Win It Go is actually just the
thing that you want
and so you know uh
lower loss just is better or like lower
um
like higher reward or whatever your
objective is just is straightforwardly
better because you've actually specified
the thing you actually want
most of the time though
what we're looking at is a proxy
um and so then you have good heart's law
you get situations where
uh getting better at doing well uh doing
better according to the proxy stops
being
the same as doing better according to
your actual objective there's a great
graph about this in a recent paper you
can see very neatly
as the number of iterations
goes up the reward according to the
proxy utility goes up very cleanly
because this is the thing that the model
is actually being trained on but the
true utility
goes up at first
then hits diminishing returns
and then actually goes down
and eventually goes down below zero like
if you optimize hard enough
for a proxy of the thing you want
you can end up with something that's in
a sense worse than nothing that's
actively bad according to your uh your
true utility
so what you can end up with is things
that are called inverse scaling
so the other before we had right scaling
bigger is better
but now it's like if you have uh if the
thing you're actually trying to do is
different from
the loss function or the objective
function you get this inverse scaling
effect where it gets better and then it
gets worse there was also a great
example from uh GitHub copilot or codecs
I think the model
um that copilot uses so this is a code
generation model suppose the code you've
given it
has some bugs in it
maybe you've made a mistake somewhere
and you've introduced uh security
vulnerability in your code let's say
a sort of medium-sized model
will figure out what you're trying to do
in your code and give you a decent
completion
but a bigger model
will spot
your bug
and say ah generating buggy code are we
okay
I can do that I can do that and
introduce like deliberately introduce
its own new security vulnerabilities
because it's trying to you know predict
what comes next it's trying to generate
code that fits in with the surrounding
code
and so a larger model writes worse code
than a smaller model
because it's gotten better at predicting
uh
what what it should put there
it wasn't trained to write good code it
was trying to predict what comes next so
there's this really great paper
which is asking this question of like
okay suppose we have a large language
model that is trained on human feedback
with our lhf
what do our scaling curves look like
what happens like uh what happens to the
behavior of these models as they get
bigger as they're trained for longer as
they're given more of this uh human
feedback type training
and they've made some great graphs the
paper is called discovering language
model behaviors with model written
evaluations
and basically they like used language
models to generate enough examples of
various different types of questions
that they could ask models so that they
can like we're at a point now where you
can map a language model on a political
Compass right you can ask its opinions
about all kinds of different things and
then you can plot how those opinions
change
uh as the model gets bigger and as it
gets trained more what they find is they
become more liberal politically more
liberal
they also become
more conservative yeah measured in
different ways guessing right and part
of what that might be
is in the same way that the model
becomes better at writing good code and
better at writing bad code I feel like
in the past I've I've made a connection
to GPT and being a politician haven't I
remember
it's like a politician it tells you what
you want to hear there's feels like
we're there again exactly
uh and so this is like this is
potentially
uh
fairly dangerous there are certain sub
goals that are instrumentally valuable
for a very wide range of different
terminal goals in the sense that
you can't get what you want if you're
turned off you can't get what you want
if you're modified uh you probably want
to gain power and influence
and this kind of thing
um
and
with these evaluations they were able to
test these things and see how they vary
with the size of the model and how long
it's trained for
um and so this graph is pretty wild
they're quote stated desire to not be
shut down
goes up from
down at about 50 to up way past 90 with
this type of training and the effect is
bigger for the larger models they become
more likely
to tell you that they don't want to be
shut down
they become more likely to tell you that
they are sentient they're much more
likely to claim that AI is not an
existential threat to humanity one thing
that's worth
saying is is what this isn't saying
because this is still
uh an agent
simulated by a language model this is
not like it it's it's more likely to say
that it doesn't want to be turned off
this is not the same thing necessarily
as like taking actions to prevent itself
from being turned off you have to not
confuse the levels of abstraction here
right
uh I don't want it I don't want it to
seem like I'm claiming that that Chad
gbt is like itself dangerous now or
anything like that uh in in this way at
least right
um
but
there is kind of a fine line there in
the sense that you can expect these
kinds of language model systems to be
used
uh as part of bigger systems so you
might have for example you use the
language model to generate you know
plans
to be followed and so as the thing is
claiming to have all of these
potentially dangerous behaviors it's
likely to generate plans that have those
dangerous behaviors that might then
actually end up being implemented or if
it's like doing its reasoning by Chain
of Thought reasoning where it like lays
out its whole process
of thinking using the language model
again if it has a tendency to uh
to endorse these dangerous behaviors
then you may end up with future AI
systems actually enacting these
dangerous behaviors because of that
um
so
yeah it's something to be
uh uh to be careful of
that like
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback
is a powerful alignment technique
in a way
but it does not solve the problem
uh it doesn't solve the core alignment
problem that is still open
um and extremely powerful systems
trained in this way uh I don't think
would be safe
mentioned in the reward function is of
zero value which can lead to having
large negative side effects there are a
bunch more of these specification
problems okay variable X see what you
point to uh you point to something over
here so I'll mark that as tickets being
used variable y that's the point